did you know that there was a college
football team that once scored 40 points
in the fourth quarter and still lost the
game it was an early season matchup
between Appalachian State and UNC and it
was one that a record-breaking crowd at
the time wasn't ready for that's because
unc's Drake made a potential first
rounder put on a show and both teams
scored the most points in their
program's history after falling behind
21-7 early UNC scored the next 34 points
in the game and was up big to start the
fourth a 20-point lead seemed like a
massive Hill for App State to climb or
so he thought Drake may had a
game-changing fumble and App State went
on to score six touchdowns in the fourth
quarter unfortunately for them UNC also
scored three of their own touchdowns and
after this tackle was made short of the
goal line the App State comeback was
over App State ended the fourth quarter
having scored 40 points and both teams
went on to combine for 62 points in the
fourth the second most in college
football history still this game will be
engraved in history even though some App
State fans are on the wrong side of it